hi I'm Maria and today A friend is
challenging me to take a popular food
and make it fancy today's guest is my
friend Jerry hey everyone it's Jerry I
am so excited to challenge Ria today are
you ready to find out what the secret
ingredient is I am ready let's bring it
in let's see what I'm making fancy today
okay late but magic Masala these India's
magic Masala potato chips are a super
popular snack in India in fact in 2012
they were the most favorited flavor in
India let's try this
I can see this became number one it's
not too spicy but it heat is differently
there there is like a hint of tanginess
I already know there was a mango there
is a tomato powder great choice okay so
you're up for the challenge well before
we wrap up I have one more challenge for
you so I brought this cookbook for you
you're going to open it up to a random
page and whatever the main ingredient is
in the recipe you have to include it in
the dish I kind of use what's up
throw nothing else in there so I I hope
I don't choose anything strange let's
see where you end up
slow roasted leg of lamb Lego Plum is
pretty fancy I have to think how I can
incorporate I'm gonna listen to you
you're the professional you can make
anything fancy so I feel like you got
this I will try to make it fancy
all right here's what I got bread
shallots lights mint potatoes Greek
yogurt Beeks garlic cilantro parsley
thyme Thai chilies Rosemary and lamb
from the palm tree I got five spice
powder garam masala cumin seed club soda
coconut sugar olive oil and MSG all
right let's get started
make it fancy first I'm going to process
this
I just want to eat it it smells good and
I'm going to keep quarter cup and I'm
going to use this for later and the rest
of the powder I'm going to use at the
next step so I have some olive oil heat
in the pan and here I have chipped bread
and I'm going to toast bread until
golden brown and then I'm going to put
leftover oil add onions
and just sprinkle a little bit salt
because it's also help cooking faster
leeks and onion get a little bit softer
so I'm going to add garlic now garlic
tended to be burnt easily so if you have
a bunch of ingredients you should add
that first and then garlic smells good
and looking good so I'm going to add
plate ingredients magic Masala potato
chip powder the onions are translucent
and leeks are soft and I'm going to add
bad toasted bread and incorporate
together right looking good and I'm
gonna take this off from the Heat and
add more flavors okay and I'm gonna add
lime juice and lime zest lime this has a
lot of good flavor that the juice
doesn't have and we have galang Masala
adding mint and parsley and I'm gonna
add salt this it's gonna gonna be flavor
explosion
spicy bites good spicy a little bit more
salt sometimes when I eat too spicy food
I feel like my ear is gonna fall off but
this one doesn't have that the bread is
still a little bit dry so I want to put
in a refrigerator so everything gonna
soak up all the goodness so I'm going to
cover this and I'm going to rest this in
a refrigerator about 30 minutes this
step I will need my little surgery
gloves leg of lamb and another tasty
hack if you don't have dedicated cutting
board for meat you can just wrap with
plastic so it doesn't cross contaminate
you want to use flat part of meat
pounder and you want to pound heat and
kind of smear the reason you want to
pound the meat is two tenderize the meat
and also you want to make a even
thickness it's going to take a little
time and I'm gonna pound this a little
more flatter but before that let's get
fancy
[Music]
all right I finished pounding the me and
trimmed me because it was a little too
big now I'm going to stuff this lamb I'm
going to put here and I'm going to roll
this over this part is a little thin so
I'm going to trim just because I want to
make sure cook evenly we are going to
cook this together and I'm going to
score just a little bit so the seasoning
kind of get into the meat it's like
diagonal and just season surface of the
meat with salt and pepper you know I'm
going to use butcher twine and make sure
to use butcher twine because if you use
other kind of string it might burn in
the oven you can find Wichita in a
grocery store and I'm going to tie this
meat because it's kind of rolled up and
if you don't tie it it's gonna fall
apart trying to make l-shape when you
tie with butcher twine you don't want to
tie too tight because while it's cooking
it's kind of like Steam and expand and
Shrink purpose of tying it's just hold
the shape all right and this is done and
I'm going to cut extra string move it to
sheet pan with cooling lock on top
beautiful I'm going to bake this at 350
oven until the internal temperature
reaches 145 let's cook some potatoes I'm
using Yukon Gold this potato is the good
potato to make a roasted potato because
it holds its shape and I have one more
tasty hack you can use heel and remove
eyes or potato and I have two chopsticks
and you're gonna just slice
the Chopsticks it's the guide so you
don't accidentally cut through this is
the half cell back potato it's the way
of cutting so I'm keeping potatoes in
water because it washes out extra starch
potato oxidizes so you want to keep in
water all right all potatoes are
hasselbacked and we are moving on to
next step I'm gonna need this shapes
so I have a stick of butter it looks
like there are too much butter but
there's not a such a thing add garam
masala black pepper and salt give a
light stir and add late Indians magic
Masala and you want to cook potato chips
until it's get softened I think late
India's magic Masala chips it's too long
so let's call it late Magic chips
smells so good if you come close to the
screen I think you can smell I'm going
to sprinkle this magic butter did you
hear that okay I'm gonna toss I did a
Hasselback cut because it will track the
all good butter and spice my lamb is
almost ready and it's a good time to put
this potato along with lamb it will take
about 30 minutes so this is a leftover
potato chips I bet this is gonna be so
good because it's soaked in butter so
let me try
hot potato chips so good I think I want
to incorporate this into my dish or I'm
gonna just eat them all so good so we
have late Magic chips and toasted cumin
seeds and coconut sugar and I'm gonna
just make it into powder and then and
add yogurt Thai Chili I think it's a lot
so my spicy Torrance is not that high so
I'm gonna just use half I'm gonna add
lime juice add all the salt right and
I'm going to perfect and I'm adding
fresh out I'm adding last when you put
fresh herbs in the beginning the process
that he kind of turns so it's kind of
brown starved is very fresh so want to
make the sauce a little bit light and
bright it's still a little chunky so I'm
going to add water because I want to
make it like a sauce looking good and
smells good this is my spicy or herb
yogurt sauce
mmm oh spicy this is a little spicy but
definitely complements my dish I think
jelly would love it like I have my flour
and adding Chinese five spice garam
masala and MSG I think MSG is a little
bit controversial ingredients but it's
basically just the Umami booster and
black pepper salt whisk it's all the
spices even the distributed a quarter
cup of ground Magic chips I saved
earlier and club soda
all right so I have batter I just made
right here and I'm going to dip sliced
shallot drop in the oil I'm going to
finish frying them and finally assemble
right so this was baked and rested and
I'm going to remove twine first I'm glad
how it turns out it is still holding the
shape because of the twine I'm gonna
give us some slice I'm going to put
spicy harv yogurt sauce on the bottom
but this top Jerry has this food
Instagram it looks so polished so I want
to make sure to impress her and we are
done
foreign
Masala spiced leg of lamb and Hasselback
potato the longest dish name but still
very fancy
all right let's bring out our special
guest Jerry hey how are you I'm pretty
I'm pretty ready for this do an open yes
okay big reveal wow
oh so wait what's happening oh okay
I made stuffing with Magic chips spicy
are yogurt sauce and Hasselback potatoes
with Magic chips infused butter you're
amazing I'm like trying to keep up with
you this looks incredible I wish you
could all smell this okay let's do it
look at that bite that's gonna be it not
very it's spicy that is incredible yay I
made the right cup they're a small
Ramekin full of Thai chili and I'm like
this might be too spicy how many did you
put in there I can handle it I can
handle it but it's a little spicy I love
potatoes if anyone knows me I love
potatoes I love a good sauce so this is
like my kryptonite right here everything
from the five spies to the garam masala
and that subtle sweetness from the
cinnamon honestly I can go scoop after
scoop this is really good Jerry did I
make lace India's magic Masada fancy you
killed it you made it fancy and went
above and beyond this is amazing let me
go and let me try this
so good I am not kidding when I say that
the taste of this is identical to the
flavors on this plate the make it fancy
Queen we have one last things to do
three two one make it fancy can I take
it now this yes absolutely
[Music]
thank you